[Música]
y hablamos de economía en directo
américa felicidad me va a saludarla
daniela blandón bienvenida a este
estudio feliz mañana del jueves para
usted vamos a hablar de los precios del
consumidor en eeuu que están totalmente
disparados hola raúl pues mire toda la
semana veníamos esperando este dato
hasta que por fin salió se conocieron
los precios de octubre y lo que hacen es
confirmar una tendencia alcista que ha
persistido durante toda la pandemia pese
a que las autoridades han señalado que
su efecto es transitorio el índice de
precios al consumidor subió un 6,2 por
ciento en los últimos 12 meses hasta
octubre como vemos en el gráfico esta es
su mayor alza anualizada en 31 años
anualizada quiere decir entre octubre
entre noviembre del año pasado y octubre
de este año y todo se debe al incremento
de los precios de la gasolina y de la
alimentación principalmente aunque
algunos analistas también lo atribuyen a
la aguda escasez de trabajadores que
está haciendo subir los salarios y a la
crisis de suministros y su mil ya eso
también de cara a la navidad antes de la
navidad de cara al ver tráiler y también
una mega festividad en eeuu los precios
por las nubes que implica esto entonces
en los consumidores de eeuu pero también
al resto del mundo los que compran por
en línea por amazon estas grandes
cadenas pues mire raúl el impacto ya se
está sintiendo donde a las familias más
les duele por ejemplo le va dar este
ejemplo en el desayuno los precios del
tocino han subido 20 por ciento en
apenas un año y los de los huevos otro
12% y ahora vamos a las calles la
gasolina subió un estrepitoso 50 por
ciento en un año y aunque los salarios
pues han subido no se mantienen al día
con esos precios y eso lo que hace es
añadir presión para que la reserva
federal suba las tasas de interés es
decir el precio del dinero si se
encarecen las tasas de la fed lo hacen
también las de los bancos y tendrán que
pagar más los usuarios por créditos de
vivienda de consumo tarjetas de crédito
y otros y el impacto sobre la región
tiene que ver con que gran parte de los
bancos centrales del mundo suelen seguir
los pasos de la fed así que puede
también haber alzas en las tasas de
interés no imagínense si los que
queremos ver eeuu en navidad no es
posible imposible vamos a ver a michigan
que van a indemnizar a los habitantes de
una comunidad que dieron agua con plomo
daniela pues mire el gobierno local de
esa ciudad es la ciudad de flint fue
acusado de pasar por alto pues los
riesgos del agua que estaban utilizando
para consumo humano los habitantes se
interpusieron una demanda después de
descubrir que el agua sal que salía de
sus grifos estaba contaminada con plomo
después de que las autoridades
comenzaran a usar este agua del río sin
tratarla adecuadamente pues un juez
acaba de aprobar un acuerdo con el que
el estado de michigan y otros
responsables van a reparar a las
víctimas con 626 millones de dólares el
dinero va a ser puesto a disposición de
los niños de esta comunidad de menos de
100.000 habitantes que estuvieron
expuestos al agua también los adultos
que muestran alguna lesión ciertos
dueños de negocios y hasta quienes hayan
pagado la factura de agua supuestamente
potable daniela y es que ni siquiera
para limpiarse los dientes está esta
noticia me acuerda la película erin
brockovich
buenísima
y que el congreso se está llevando a
cabo en guatemala le voy a hablar de una
fruta que yo sé que usted le encanta
cuántos aguacates podría comercios en el
día bueno lo que tenga el frente yo creo
que 3 yo también podría comer mete todos
los aguacates que hubiera en la mesa
pues se trata del congreso
latinoamericano de aguacate el cuarto
congreso y se lleva a cabo en guatemala
en el que participan más de 300
productores y exportadores y expertos en
la producción y comercialización de esta
fruta de la región están reunidos aunque
de manera virtual en la colonia en la
colonial ciudad de antigua guatemala
apenas a 40 kilómetros de la capital y
considerada la cuna del aguacate a nivel
internacional ahora le invito a que
hagamos unas cifras este país produjo el
año pasado 145 mil toneladas exportables
y genera 13.000 empleos directos y 4 mil
empleos indirectos pero en la región hay
otros grandes productores como méxico
colombia perú y chile y su aporte no es
poco la industria aguacatera
latinoamericana aporta al mercado
internacional cerca del 80 por ciento de
la fruta que se consume principalmente
el aguacate as que es el que en la voto
de dirigentes deliciosos y bueno dan y
ahora vamos con los indicadores
económicos del día de hoy bueno pues
estos temores inflacionarios no es que
hayan asustado tampoco mucho a las
bolsas asiáticas que cerraron mixtas
aunque sí empujaron al dólar a su máximo
en 16 meses en europa las bolsas operan
en positivo media marcha luego de que la
comisión europea elevará las
perspectivas de crecimiento para este
año aunque bajo las de la oriental de
rápidamente cifra el día 155 mil
millones de dólares es el valor en bolsa
que ha perdido tesla en apenas tres días
desde que es un fundador y lan más
anunció que vendería parte de sus
acciones para liberar recursos y pagar
impuestos más recito le cuento porque
esta cita así es daniela entonces le
salió caro el chistecito a lomos que la
encuesta a los inversionistas más que
vernos de gràcia sant y por toda la
información es vamos a más adelante
entonces con más economía nosotros vamos
directo a glasgow
[Música]